Get baited.
You get zero loops!
That's right.
I got my food.
So no loop for you.
If you guys want a loop, just play the video.
It's uploaded.
Just play the video.
So I can get my ad revenue.
Guys, you must be like, wow, Doki, you were gone for like almost one week and all you care about is money now?
Yes, because moving was expensive.
Guys, I need every penny I can get right now.
Holy shit.
I did not realize how expensive moving was.
Vacation, it was not a vacation.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Anyway, guys, for those who are like, Doki, please, loop.
Play this video so I can get my ad revenue.
Loop, loop this.
If I owned a house I would live there until I'd fucking die.
I learned a leave ever again.
The dragon.
Give us back to loop.
Welcome back, by the way.
Thank you for the super cha you, thank you, thank you, Sean.
Thank you for this super cha.
Thank you.
Thank you, super shock.
Thank you for this super cha.
Empty voltage.
Thank you, thank you, my teacher!
No guys, no, you don't understand!
This is like... okay.
I moved around a lot before in the past.
Like, I've like, you know...
I've always been moving.
But like...
This is the first time I've ever moved all by myself.
Like, I've done it all...
Like, usually my parents would help me with stuff like that.
Like, finding a place...
Having a car to help me with moving...
Arranging everything...
But this is the very first time...
I did almost everything myself.
Except for like, there were some parts.
And...
I'm a real adult now.
And this is the first time...
I've ever like...
Paid for everything myself too.
So like, now I actually know how much everything costs.
So...
Is this...
Is this the first time...
I've actually like, looked at how much everything costs.
And I was like...
Holy fucking shit!
Okay...
Yeah, so...
I'm finally moving to...
Like...
Okay, so...
I don't know how to stream right now.
It's been a while.
You know, like when you're out of your routine.
You're out of your fucking routine.
And...
You're just like...
How do I...
How do I do this again?
How do I interact with people?
How do I not be antisocial?
So, I need a while to like, get into...
Into the groove of things.
Also, HonGeorge!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
I just got my own house this month.
Is this a good time to tell you?
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
But yes, for those who's never moved before...
Or have always had their parents help them...
Or like, relatives or friends help them...
And like, they've never done the adult move...
Um...
To like...
Uh...
Hahaha!
To...
To pay for like, the move and everything...
And all the other stuff...
It is a lot!
It...
I...
If I had to pick between...
Uh...
Hahaha!
Living at a place...
Forever...
Uh...
And die there...
Instead of ever going to another place again...
I would definitely pick the first option.
I would...
I never...
Oh my God!
Thank you so much for the red carpet!
That's a lot of red!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
Here's the red carpet for your new place.
Glad to have you back bro!
Give us a...
No!
No loops for you!
Literally, there's a whole video for you to loop in!
There's a reason why there's a video!
Hahaha!
Um...
Oh my God!
Thank you!
Thank you everybody for the Akas!
I really appreciate it!
Thank you everybody!
Oh my God!
I really...
Okay look, I'll give you guys the next best thing.
Give me a sec.
I'll give you guys...
I'll give you guys the next best thing.
Okay?
Instead of...
Instead of a...
Okay, where is it?
Where...
Wow!
What is it called?
Oh my God!
Thank you everybody!
I feel like a celebrity!
Okay, it was funny.
Okay, I tweeted it.
I tweeted about it.
But, um...
When...
Um...
By the way, I'm still at my old apartment right now.
I'm not at the new place yet.
Because like...
Uh...
They...
I told them to take this last.
Because, you know...
I still need to work.
You know?
So...
I still have my PC here.
Um...
But, what was funny was when...
Oh my God!
I found Steve Nakasupa!
Thank you!
I want to be part of the thing too!
I don't want to miss out on the FOMO!
Oh my God!
Thank you everybody!
But like...
Um...
When I was working with the realtor...
Uh...
Agent...
Um...
They were like...
Because like...
You know...
They were...
For those who don't know...
We've never done the process of like...
Renting a place.
By the way, it's so difficult to find a place here.
Because it's so competitive.
And like...
And also like...
There's assholes that fucking...
You know...
Buying places just for Airbnbs.
This is why I fucking hate Airbnbs.
Uh...
Not only are there like...
Very asshole...
Like...
Landlords for Airbnbs.
That are like...
Really creep...
Sometimes really creepy...
Or like...
Really strict about the rules...
Of Airbnbs.
They buy up majority of the properties here.
And they don't rent it out.
They...
It's all like...
Just like...
You have to get it from Airbnbs.
So fuck that shit!
Uh...
So...
So it's super competitive and everything too.
It's so fucked.
They're like...
Ruining the house...
We're gonna have another...
God damn housing bubble crash.
Because of it.
Anyway...
Um...
So...
For those who've never like...
Rented or like...
Uh...
Tried to get a place before...
Um...
What you need...
Is to send in pay stubs...
That you're employed.
You know?
That you can...
Afford!
To like...
Pay for a place!
Well...
Obviously...
I get paid...
By...
YouTube.
So...
That's...
So then...
Like by Google and YouTube.
I had to like...
I had to...
I basically sent in...
The...
Like the...
The YouTube payments and stuff.
But I didn't like...
Link my channel or anything.
I didn't like...
Link it.
So I just...
Was just showed like...
The pay stubs.
Like okay...
Here's like the deposits...
From...
Like YouTube.
Because...
Like they're like...
Who are you employed by?
And then I wrote...
Me.
It was like...
I was like...
Who's your employer?
Because you have to give like...
Contact information...
Of...
Your employer...
And everything.
So I literally wrote...
Me.
I am the boss.
And then...
And then I was like...
I own...
The company.
And then I just put my own phone number.
I was just like...
My own...
Like they're like...
What's their phone number?
So we could call them.
And then I put my own phone number.
And...
And then like...
So the realtor agent was like...
I was like...
When they were showing me the place...
They were like...
Oh yeah!
Hey!
This is me!
What do you do?
It's my first time working with a YouTube creator!
I've never worked with one before!
And then I was like...
NDA!
I was like...
I'm not fucking telling you!
Like what the fuck!
Like...
I was just like...
Haha!
NDA!
When you know I'm fucking...
Who am I signing NDA for?
I literally work for myself.
So like...
I was just like...
I am my own NDA!
Hahaha!
So I was like...
I didn't sign anything...
But...
You don't know that!
Like...
Haha!
Um...
You mean you own the company?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
The NDA that I drafted myself!
I wrote like...
I'm like...
Um...
Ron Swanson and Parks and Rec.
And then I write on the paper.
And it's like...
I am the boss!
Like...
Hahaha!
I just write on the paper.
NDA!
And then I sign it.
I sign my name on it.
Haha!
Nox!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
It's me!
I'm the boss!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh yeah!
Sorry!
Forgot to give you guys...
The next best thing for a loop.
Give me a sec.
I got really distracted there.
Hahaha!
Give me a sec.
I need to find...
I need to find the file.
Alright.
Let's see.
Um...
Is it this?
No.
It has to be this.
It's not.
That's my signature.
Is it this?
Oh my god!
Okay.
Sorry.
I don't remember my stuff.
Uh...
Oh!
Is it my debut?
Has to be.
Right?
No.
It's not.
Guys.
I'm sorry.
I don't remember where everything is.
Like...
Hahaha!
I don't!
I don't remember where I put my own stuff!
Ah!
Oh wait.
Is it this?
Is this one?
No.
I don't think it is.
Is it?
No.
What?
Where did I put it?
Oh!
I put it here!
Oh I'm so stupid!
Alright guys.
I figured it out.
Guys it's been a while.
Please be gentle.
Please be nice to me.
Hahaha!
It's been a while.
Please be nice to me.
Hahaha!
Okay.
I don't know how loud this is gonna be so I'm sorry.
Whoa!
Was it loud?
I couldn't tell.
Um...
If it is I'm sorry.
How do I do this?
How loud is this?
Okay.
Um...
We're gonna put this right here.
Okay.
No.
Not here.
Alright.
We're gonna...
Hahaha!
Okay.
We're gonna...
No.
I know.
I paused it.
I know it's muted guys.
I literally paused it.
Alright.
Is it this?
Okay.
There we go.
This is...
This is what you get.
This is basically what you get.
Hahaha!
I'll put it down too.
Alright.
Anyway.
Um...
Hahaha!
You're gonna be...
Okay.
Um...
As I was saying...
So yeah.
Moving has been...
Has been really tough.
Um...
I actually went to buy more boxes.
I went to buy...
Uh...
Boxes today.
I actually went to buy more boxes.
Uh...
More boxes today.
Also...
Um...
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
I'm still at work!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
Okay.
So like...
I...
I bought like...
I had to buy boxes at Home Depot.
Um...
And it was really tough.
Because like...
I had to get the boxes myself.
And...
Um...
Oh yeah.
I forgot to put it on a loop.
Because it's gonna stop after this one.
Let me actually put it on a loop.
And...
And like...
I...
I called an Uber.
And...
And I was like...
Hey...
Um...
I didn't really...
I bought too much.
I bought...
No car...
Guys.
I have not driven a car...
In...
Six years.
No.
I have my license.
I have not...
I do not think you should ever...
I...
I should not be behind the wheel.
I haven't...
I...
I have not touched the wheel in six plus years.
For the safety of everybody.
I should absolutely not be behind the car.
Like I...
So...
Um...
So I do have a license.
I just...
I choose not to drive.
Because it's been way too long.
For the safety of everybody on the road.
And not on the road.
So...
Background is very low.
Well...
Sorry but...
You're not here to listen to the BGM.
Like...
Like what do you mean?
I'm here...
I'm here to talk.
Like...
Anyway... Why is there chat?
You don't wanna be there?
Let me... Okay.
Anyway, anyway, so... It was awkward because like...
So I had to like, obviously, I had to hold the... I bought too many boxes.
And like, because like, fucking, I don't know.
I've never done all of this myself before.
And um... Quiet please, I'm trying to chat.
So like, I overestimated how well I can carry boxes.
Because like, because like, I don't know if you guys know this, but it's...
It's really big, the...
And like... So like, I couldn't hold it in like, two arms.
Like, I can't hold it in like, two arms.
And I bought way too many.
I was... Because like, you know, I had like a cart.
So I was like, you know, driving with my cart.
And like, put... And I was like, that doesn't seem too bad.
Um... And um...
And like...
And like... So obviously, when I loaded into the car...
Uh, by the way, I wasn't driving the car.
So don't worry, everybody was safe.
Uh...
And I was just like... First off, I was like, how do I fit this in the car?
Um, and... Because like... I was like, how do I fit it?
It's so long.
And then, we were just looking at it.
Like, me and the driver.
We were just looking at it and figuring it out.
And then, they're like, can I bend it?
And I was like, you can bend...
I'm so smart.
I like, texted my friend too.
I texted my friend.
I was like, I'm so smart.
If you bend the cardboard in half, it makes it smaller.
So that it would fit in the car trunk.
And I was like, oh my god.
I was just like...
I was like...
Because it's a giant cardboard.
Because it's flat.
And it's like, I bought the big ones.
And like... And I was like, oh my god.
And I was like...
And then, my friend was just like, so cute.
Dot, dot, dot, dot, dot.
And I was like, oh my...
That's so much easier.
Because I was like, how am I going to carry this?
Like, it's so long.
I can't carry this.
And then the driver was like, oh, can I bend it to fit in the trunk?
I was like, it blew my mind.
It blew my mind.
I was just like, you can bend the cardboard.
Because that's what they're supposed to be used for.
You can bend it.
Anyway...
Anyway, after I realized you can bend the cardboard.
It was a lot easier to take back to the apartment.
It was...
So...
So there was that.
There was...
That happened...
Today.
Anyway, for those who weren't reading the waiting room chat.
Okay, this has looped enough.
Like...
This has looped enough.
That's enough.
That's all you guys get.
Anyway, so...
So I ordered fiber internet.
Because obviously I need fiber for my job.
And...
And like...
So...
For those who don't know, like, TELUS fiber...
Okay, let me...
I use TELUS, by the way.
Because in Canada, it's either TELUS or Rogers.
Because like...
You know, we...
We all know like internet com...
Like, unlike Australia.
Or I don't know if the New Zealand's like it too.
Or if they're like actually normal like the rest of us.
The government does not allow us to use fiber.
It doesn't own the internet company.
For like...
For all you Australians who don't know this.
The government doesn't own the internet.
Okay, who cares about Bell?
Nobody cares about Bell.
Like...
It's so irrelevant.
Because like...
Even like in price comparison...
It's always...
TELUS would be like...
Here's our prices compared to Rogers.
Because they don't think Bell exists.
They don't think Bell exists.
They don't think Bell is not like relevant to them.
Um...
I like how someone was like...
Bell is still around?
Like...
So...
Um...
We have an option to have better internet.
Because the government doesn't control it.
Um...
And the package for fiber is pretty fucking crazy.
Because like...
Uh...
It's like...
There's...
Pure fiber.
Um...
There's like...
Pure fiber.
And then there's like...
There's like...
Fiber.
Uh...
And then there's pure fiber X.
And then I got the...
I don't remember what it's called.
It was like...
Some fucking...
Some...
Ultra...
Ultra something something something.
I was like...
Why is that name so long?
Why...
Why is...
Why is that such a fucking...
Long...
Name...
Let's see.
Let me...
Let me see the package title.
Um...
Oh, my gosh.
Where is it?
Okay.
Fiber.
Teleteles.
Package.
Where's the pictures for it?
Where's the pictures?
Okay.
Package.
Uh...
Was it Ultra Mega Fiber X?
I was like...
Trying to find the packages.
Because I want...
Okay.
Okay, what's this?
No, it's not that.
Alright.
Where was it?
What was it called?
Any like, telus people know what it was called?
Because I don't remember.
I don't remember.
I was looking it up because I was like, Do I do that?
Do I...
Do I get that internet?
Like I was just like, do I...
I mean it was like $20 more.
So I was just like, I mean...
It was...
Oh, it's PureFiberX Internet.
I'm like, okay, so...
Because it's 3x.
And the thing about it is that...
The other ones are like a thousand.
Or a thousand upload, download.
And the package I got was...
3000 upload and download.
Oh yeah, sorry, Internet 3G.
I forgot.
It's PureFiberX Internet 3G.
So it's...
I call it UltraFiber.
Because...
Basically, I call it UltraFiber.
Because it's 3000 uploads.
And 3000 downloads.
And then the other plans, the other package deals are like, Oh, you can connect like 20 devices and stuff.
And everything.
And then the other one was like, Oh, you can connect like 6 to 12 devices.
And the PureFiberX Internet 3G...
They're like, you can connect 100 devices.
And I was like, oh my God.
What am I going to do with 100 devices?
I was like, what am I going to do with 100 plus devices?
I was like, okay.
But 100 plus devices can connect to my Internet.
And...
So that's why.
Probably it's for businesses but I was like, you know what?
What if?
I'm just saying.
It was $20 more.
Okay.
All I was saying was the reason why I paid.
I mean.
I mean, it was a 1000 or 3000.
And the whole reason.
The reason why I... I was like it's only $20 more!
It's $20 more for 3k?
Like that shit is... I mean, come on!
What a fucking deal!
Like...
Like, what a deal!
Nobody else is allowed to use it except for me.
But like...
All I'm saying was that... I don't know if I'll ever need 3k uploads or downloads.
But, like, what if something happens?
What if I needed to download a 100GB game and I had 10 minutes to do it?
Like, what if?
I'll be prepared!
Exactly!
I'll always be prepared for it!
And it's a business expense!
It's literally for my job!
So...
Like, what if?
Exactly!
I could technically stream in 4k!
But I won't do it!
I could technically do it!
But I won't!
But I like that there is an option.
I like that I have the option to do it!
It is a business expense!
It's literally my job!
We love tax write-offs here!
Um...
Thomas!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh, look at that loser!
Good morning, Doki!
I am Thomas, the poor one in ACGHK!
Love you!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright, for those who don't understand who Thomas is...
Um... I played Apex...
For... with like... some of the dragoons in Hong Kong.
And... um...
Um... we were picking some dragoons randomly.
Um... and they were playing with us.
Thomas here was like...
Yeah, I'm good at the game.
So I was like... Alright, Thomas!
I was like... Alright!
Let's see how you do!
Um... needless to say...
Thomas sort of... you know...
Apparently, he was a controller player.
Forced to play on MNK.
So...
Um... we weren't even...
I found out later on... he was a controller player.
That unfortunately, we didn't have any controllers at the premises.
So... yeah.
So it was an unlucky day for Thomas when it came to like...
Playing in front of everybody.
And then... you know...
He got...
He got roasted!
A little bit.
Just a little bit, guys.
I didn't make him cry.
Um... and he liked it.
So like...
In the end... like... we're all winners here.
Um...
So everybody won in the end.
Because is it really... like... is it really fucked up?
If Thomas liked it in the end?
All... that's all I'm saying...
It will hold up in court, by the way.
This will hold up in court.
Like...
Alright.
Let me munch on my sandwich.
I got sandwiched because it was like the fastest...
Um... the fastest thing to get here.
So...
I won't say what type of sandwich because I don't want to fucking dox myself.
I'm trying to find a very... specific sandwich.
Um...
Hi, Drake.
I haven't talked this much in a long time.
Sorry.
Um... I haven't talked this much in a while.
So like... I need...
My throat is just like...
What the fuck are you doing?
Like...
They're like...
Please...
Hydrate.
What are you doing, Dokie?
Fucking hydrate.
But I really miss streaming though.
I really, really do.
It's... it's been a mess.
Um... I remember like... I had to...
Um... I tried to find boxes.
The reason why I bought boxes so late was because...
I had a huge problem trying to fucking...
I don't know why!
It's so hard to find moving boxes.
Um...
Close to me.
And...
The reason... I was trying to find...
Like... moving boxes.
And the closest thing...
I went to Walmart first.
Because like...
Walmart sells moving boxes.
It's literally on their website.
And I was... I... I was so tired.
I like walked there.
Because I was like...
I don't wanna... I don't wanna take an Uber.
Like... I don't wanna take an Uber.
So... I was like...
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna walk to Walmart.
And...
I was so tired.
That...
In the middle of walking to Walmart...
I passed by an ice cream store.
So... like...
And my staff team was helping me out with the move and everything.
Um...
Because they were much more experienced with like...
Moving and stuff.
And I'm not.
Like...
Not on my own.
And they like doing it on my own.
Um...
So like...
My staff team was helping me.
With like...
Some of...
Some of the stuff that was going on.
And...
Um...
Because they're like much older than me.
And so they have like...
Actual experience.
Because they're old.
Uh...
Like...
Um...
Which is a compliment.
The older you are...
The more wisdom you have.
And...
Uh...
So...
In the middle...
They were like...
How's it go...
Like...
Because they were like trying to help me find like places to get moving boxes.
And...
So...
I was like...
You can't say...
Yes, I can.
Because I literally paid their...
Wages.
So...
I shouldn't say that.
Like...
That's so fucked up.
I'm sorry.
I should...
Stop it.
I'm so...
I'mop...
Please...
Please don't...
Um...
Please...
Please continue the work for me.
Um...
Anyways.
I didn't mean that.
Um...
Anyway.
I was joking.
I was...
Joking.
Anyways...
Alright...
Anyway, as I was saying, they were like, how's it going?
And then I literally was like...
I literally was like...
I was like...
They texted...
Not texted, they Discord messaged, like, how's it going?
Did you find the boxes?
Cause you know, I sort of stayed at the ice cream place for like 30 minutes.
And I literally wrote back, sorry I'm at the ice cream store cause I'm dead inside.
And they were like, understandable.
It was really hot!
Okay?
So I was there for like 30 minutes cause I just needed the break, okay?
And...
Cause they expected me to already... would have bought the boxes already.
Because I was gone for like a long time.
But...
Instead I was at the ice cream store, like, eating my ice cream.
Anyway, back onto the main quest.
Getting the fucking boxes at Walmart.
Dude, okay, I don't care!
Fuck Walmart!
I was like, no Dokie!
You're gonna lose a potential sponsor with Walmart.
If I'm willing to cut any cord...
If I'm willing to cut any fucking cord...
Any connection to any corporation...
It will be fucking Walmart.
Cause fuck Walmart!
For what they did to me.
And the reason why I'm passionate about my hate towards Walmart...
Is because...
I was sent on the fucking wildest goose chase...
Trying to find moving boxes.
No one knew where the moving boxes were!
I was sent everywhere!
I was like, I asked six different people for boxes!
But it was on their website!
It was literally on their website!
You can pick it up today!
That's what it says on the website!
So like...
I'll be like, hi, I'm looking for moving boxes.
And they're like, oh, um, sorry, I don't know.
Maybe it's like...
Maybe it's in the home area.
So I was like, okay.
And I walked around, I swear to God, I walked around the goddamn wall.
I walked around Walmart for like...
For almost like...
An hour and a half!
Trying to find the fucking boxes!
And then I like...
Walked around and I kept going...
And then I asked another person.
And they're like, oh, maybe it's like...
Downstairs.
Maybe it's like...
On the...
Maybe it's on the first floor instead of the third floor.
And I was like, oh, okay.
I'll check the first floor out.
And I walked around.
And I asked another person.
They're like, oh, wait, I think it's like...
At the hardware section.
And like, you basically go up to the...
Second floor.
And...
Turn that way and then go to the hardware section.
And I looked at the hardware section.
There were no fucking boxes!
There was...
Bubble wrap.
There was bubble wrap.
There was tape.
But no boxes!
And I was like, oh, maybe I fucked up.
You know?
I was like, maybe...
Maybe...
I fucked up.
Cause like, I always fuck up.
So, you know, I was like...
Could a big...
Conglomerate...
God, words.
Could a big multi-billion dollar company...
Really not have...
Fucking moving parts?
That says on their website...
That they have moving boxes...
That can be picked up today?
Cause I checked on the website...
And it was like, you can pick up these moving boxes...
Today!
And I was like, oh, today.
Like...
Oh, today!
Cause I was like, why wait...
To order it online...
If I can just go there and pick it up...
Right now.
So...
Anyway...
I was like...
I walked...
I walked around!
For a very long time!
Because I kept thinking...
It's my fault!
It's fucking my fault!
And finally, after asking 5 plus people...
I found the 6th guy.
And I was like...
Okay, the 6th guy was the 5th guy.
By the way, I found the same guy again.
Cause he was the most confident.
About...
He was literally the...
Cause he actually gave me directions.
So...
I was like...
Okay, I'm gonna ask this guy...
The 5th guy again.
Because he literally actually gave me...
Real fucking directions.
On where the boxes were.
And so...
So...
I was like...
Hey, I walked there!
I walked to that specific section you told me.
And there's no boxes!
And then he was like...
Oh really?
Okay, let me call them.
And I was like...
Yeah, I checked the Walmart website.
And that's why I came here.
At this particular store.
Because it said I could pick up...
Boxes today.
Cause you have them in stock.
And then that man straight up told me...
That fucking man...
It's not his fault!
But still...
Like...
He's...
He paid minimum wage!
But still...
I'm sorry!
This is why I'm being...
A minimum wage worker fucking sucks.
Cause I was so angry.
But I did not direct my anger towards him.
He was like...
Yeah...
That doesn't mean today.
I was like...
Why did he say pick up today?
He literally was like...
Sorry, that doesn't...
On the website it doesn't mean today.
And I was just like...
And they're like...
Yeah, if you place an order...
Then we actually don't have it in stock.
They'll just change the pick up date for another time.
And then...
They'll send you an email and be like...
Sorry, you're gonna pick it up at this date...
I'm like...
They say it!
Just put it on the website!
What if it was an emergency?
What if I ordered something...
At Walmart...
I don't know...
What if my backyard...
Was filled with deadly mold...
And I went to the Walmart...
To pick up pesticides...
Cause I need it today.
Cause if I don't...
I'm gonna get cancer or something.
I don't know, it's fucking dead black mold.
I'm like...
What if it was black mold?
In my house?
And like...
I need it now!
And I saw...
Walmart has the materials that I need...
For it.
And I pick today!
Pick up today!
It's already too late.
Like...
Okay...
Anyway...
Um...
I was so mad.
I was so mad!
I was like...
Why would you lie about that?
Why the fuck...
Why the fuck did you lie?
Why the fuck does Walmart lie about today?
It could have been a fucking emergency!
But it wasn't.
Because I went to Home Depot the other day.
So...
So the next day I went to Home Depot cause clearly it was an emergency.
But it could have been!
That's the thing!
It could have been an emergency!
Because Walmart is right today!
Okay, sorry.
Anyway...
He was like...
Yeah...
Today was a lie.
So...
Anyway...
They were like...
Um...
Yeah, that's not true.
It's not today.
We don't have it and stuff.
We just put it there just in case we do have it and stuff.
So...
They called...
Oh yeah, we don't have a Target in Canada because they went bankrupt.
I don't know how it's fucking Target.
Like I don't know!
We got one!
Like I don't know how the fuck Target went bankrupt in Canada!
Because we still have Toys R Us!
For some reason, Toys R Us went bankrupt in America!
But we haven't!
But yet, we don't have a fucking Target!
Like how?!
It's convenient!
How the fuck does Toys R Us stay alive?
But not Target!
We don't have enough children for Toys R Us!
Like, I don't understand!
We don't have enough children!
We have a lower population than America!
Yet somehow...
Our population is sustaining the Toys R Us in the country!
Uh...
It makes no sense!
Anyway...
Um...
Sorry, anyway...
There's a lot of things I'm mad about!
There's a lot of things!
Uh...
Um...
Anyway...
So anyway...
The guy... The fifth slash sixth guy...
Fifth guy part two...
Called the like...
I guess the inventory people...
And uh...
What grinds... You know what grinds my gears?
So...
Um...
The fifth guy part two...
Called the inventory person...
And was like...
Sorry, we don't have any boxes...
We don't have...
It's out of stock...
And I was like...
Oh my... This entire time it was fucking out of stock...
I've been trapped in this Walmart for like...
An hour and a half...
And all along it was out of stock... I'm tired!
I walked so long to get here...
To this specific Walmart...
And it was out of stock...
The website lied to me...
I could've been at Home Depot...
I chose Walmart cause it was...
Closer!
I could've...
I could've been at Home Depot!
Anyway...
Um...
Um... So... Yeah...
So the trip was... I mean I wouldn't say the trip...
Was like a failure...
Because I did get ice cream in the end... Like...
I did... I did...
In the middle of the quest I got ice cream...
So like... There's that...
Also... I was...
It added to my anger...
Another reason why I was angry...
Was because I bought... There was like a...
Not Toys R Us by the way...
There was like a toy store...
Like a collector toy store...
Nearby... And I checked it out...
Cause I haven't been there in a long time...
Cause I really... I wanted to see if they still had...
This specific figure that I really really like...
Um... Let me see what it's called...
Um...
Let me see if I can remember what it's called...
Uh... Because it is a...
It's really cute... I really love...
The... Uh...
I really love the... Uh...
The brand... Because like...
I thought it was like really really cute...
I'm gonna try and find a picture of it real quick right now...
Give me a sec... Cause I need you guys...
Cause like... I got mad...
I got mad...
There's so many things...
I did... I had a really...
Rough week... Okay... I had a...
Really rough week...
It was... It was a lot of things...
That made me mad...
The past week... But like...
This one... I was... I'm just...
I'll just say it... Like...
There's a lot of things that happened I couldn't really talk about...
Publicly... But like...
It's not like business related...
It's more so like personal related...
Um...
And like... I...
Had so many unlucky...
Things happen to me...
In the past week...
It was absolutely fucking crazy...
I was like... How do I...
I was like... How is this still happening?
How is this still fucking happening?
Like...
Um... I mean there was like...
Unlucky business stuff too... Like losing my fucking...
Fortnite creator code...
Um... I'll talk about that story later...
But um...
I need to show you guys...
Why... This particular...
Um...
Toy store... The...
The collector toy store...
Made me mad...
I...
I've just been...
Because I've been so unlucky!
I don't understand!
Like... I'm sorry...
My voice is definitely not used to talking for so long...
I've just... I've been so fucking unlucky!
What is it called?
Okay... I need to find it...
Oh my god...
I can't remember like...
The name of... Is this the brand?
Is it... Oh!
Oh!
It is!
Okay... Okay...
The brand is called... Is it What The Bird?
Do they have the other ones?
Okay...
What the... What...
What The Bird... I think that's what it's called...
I'm gonna try and find...
The series... Okay... So...
I really love their...
Uh... Their bird...
Their collection...
Because it's super cute...
I think like... I'm trying to see...
Oh!
It's called Love Bird!
Not What The Bird...
That's like one of their collections...
Um... It's called Love Bird...
And it's super cute...
But they did something that made me so angry...
But it's not because of them...
I just wanted to reiterate...
It's not because of them...
It's...
It's because...
Okay... Love Bird Collection...
Figures... Where is it?
Where's that spec... Is it called Love...
Okay... It is...
Okay... It's Love Bird Series...
Okay... So... The reason being...
Is that I'll show you guys the collection...
I'll show...
I'll show you guys the collection...
And I really...
There was one that I really really wanted...
And...
Obviously I didn't get it... But...
If I did get it...
I wouldn't be mad...
So...
So... This is the collection...
This is...
This is the collection...
And I wanted the bad...
Bad birdie... Because I thought I was...
I thought he was so fucking cool...
I wanted...
I wanted the... I wanted the bad...
Bad birdie...
And... The thing is...
I didn't realize...
That I had this in stock...
Because... The first time I bought this...
Was...
Five months ago...
Or was it four?
It was either four or five months ago...
And I got...
I got poor guy bird...
So obviously...
Poor guy bird was pretty cool too...
Five months passed!
You see where I'm going?
Yeah...
Five months passed!
I saw they still had them!
I saw this particular toy collection store.
They were still selling them.
And I was like, oh, I don't mind getting any of the other six other figures in this collection.
I grabbed a random box.
I opened it as I went out of the store.
Right the moment I went out of the store.
Like, just bought it and just went out.
It was poor Godford.
Five months later.
How?
I literally waited five months.
How unlucky can I be?
Anyway, I was like, I've been really unlucky the past week.
And I managed to get a double five months later.
Which I was like, how is that possible?
There's seven!
The thing about...
Okay, you know like what's the craziest thing?
If you guys never collect like Asian gachas.
You know, toys before.
When you buy from...
Because it's all in like...
They have like a box, right?
They have a big box.
And the big box...
Has one of each.
There's no special rates.
That's the most messed up part.
Like, it's one of one.
So every box you pick up, it's a different figure.
How the fuck did I...
There's literally no doubles in the boxes.
And they're not random.
I just somehow...
I didn't even pick
the middle.
And just...
Yeah, it's...
Sorry, it's sad.
There's no gacha rates.
There's literally no gacha rates.
It's literally...
If you buy the entire collection from the box itself.
You get everything.
You get every single figure.
In there.
So somehow...
I managed to get the same one.
So...
That made me mad too.
This was before Walmart.
So...
This was before...
This was...
This was before Walmart.
So...
Yeah.
So that's why...
That's why I've been very unlucky.
There's like so many other unlucky stuff that happened to me.
But like this was one of those moments.
This was...
This was one of them.
This series...
It was definitely a series of very, very unfortunate events.
That happened to me.
The past week.
Yeah.
So...
That's been...
That's been my week.
I mean there's other stuff that's happened.
There's other stuff that's happened.
There's so many things that happened in the world too.
Like the Olympics.
JP, thank you for the Akka Supa.
Thank you.
Also thank you everybody for the super chats and the memberships.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you everybody.
Housewarming gift part two.
Unlucky prevention fun.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Akka Supa.
I really miss streaming though.
I just...
I definitely miss like chatting with you guys.
And venting a little.
Like...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh.
What a funny...
Okay.
It wasn't funny.
Cause like I felt really bad.
Cause like...
Um...
It was like...
I suppose...
There was like...
So...
Um...
So like I'm a guest.
Guest at Yuusan's concert.
And we're discussing about like...
What to do.
And when...
In the intermission.
And...
Um...
And then they were like...
Oh!
Joki, can you like...
Teach Yuusan some...
Some...
Um...
Hong Kong Cantonese slang.
And I was like...
I don't...
I...
I'm sorry.
I don't...
I was like...
I...
I'm sorry but I don't...
I don't...
No...
I was like...
I didn't...
I...
I lived in Canada.
For the first...
10 years of my life.
I'm so...
And...
Because like...
It was so funny because...
I was like...
Yuusan was like...
Oh yeah!
Like you know...
Similar to...
This word.
I was like...
What's that word?
I'm sorry.
I don't know what that means.
And...
And then...
Um...
And I was like...
I know one...
I literally only...
Know...
One...
Like one slang.
And it was like...
San cha siu hou ge san lei.
And then...
I was like...
I don't know man.
That feels too trauma dumpy.
Like...
I was like...
I...
Because...
What that means...
Is that...
That's when your...
Your mom would tell you this.
And it means...
Giving birth to...
A...
Giving birth to pork...
Is better than...
Giving birth to you.
And I was like...
I don't know if I should...
Teach that.
Like...
I don't...
So...
So that was scrapped.
Because I was like...
I don't know...
I don't feel...
I'm barely...
I'm barely a student, let alone a teacher.
So...
Yeah.
I was like...
I...
I don't think we should...
I don't think you should do any games where I have to teach you anything.
Because like...
I...
I'm barely...
We are surviving on English alone.
Let alone other languages.
Oh yeah, one of them was that, oh, why don't you teach us nursery rhymes?
We could do something easy like London Bridge is falling down.
And I was just like, I can do it in English?
I was like, I don't fucking know.
I was like, there's a Cantonese version?
I was surprised.
I was like, there's a Cantonese version of London Bridge is falling down?
I was like, I can do that in English?
I don't know.
If you want me to teach you, the only like, like, Cantonese song that I sort of know is Monica.
Because like, that was like my parents' favorite from my childhood.
I'm like, Leslie?
It's like, dance, dance, dance, dance, Monica.
But also because it's half in English too.
I only know the English parts.
Like, I literally only know the English parts of that song.
That's it.
And they're like, what about like, they're like, oh, what about you sing like classic Cantonese anime openings?
And I was like, I know them in English?
They said like Hamtaro, the Cantonese opening of Hamtaro.
I was like, oh, I grew up with that in English because it came out when I was in Canada.
So I was just like, I don't know.
It came out when I was in Canada.
I was like, I was like, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Any kid oriented stuff.
Like, my child.
I like, I went back to Hong Kong.
To visit family and stuff like Hong Kong and like other parts in China visit family.
But I missed out on like the childhood stuff.
I missed out.
And like, and like I experienced a lot of like Hong Kong stuff like later on when I was like a teenager.
Not when I was a child.
I had like, I would watch like, you know, TVB and stuff.
And like Pearl.
To like gain knowledge in Cantonese.
So anyway.
And anyway.
No, I was born in Canada.
I've been very... I was born in Canada.
But I would come go back to...
I did live in Hong Kong for a little bit.
But like it was at a later stage of my life.
So it was...
Oh yeah, and Steven Chow movies and Zhao Xingqi.
Zhao Xingqi.
Hey.
So, so it was so funny because they're like, okay.
All right.
We need you to teach...
We need you to teach nursery rhymes.
And I was like, I did not grow up with it.
I'm just like...
I did not...
I did not grow up with it.
Like the anime shows I did.
The Cantonese anime shows.
I grew up with.
Were like very, very, very old.
Because they were like hand-me-downs from my parents' generations.
So there's like...
Suyinzi.
Suyinzi and...
Like...
You know that part?
I don't know.
I don't...
Because I was a child when I listened to it.
I'm fucking...
I'm fucking stupid.
I just process the...
I process the like...
The sounds.
But I didn't process the lyrics.
And so...
So it was like...
That's...
All I remember was like...
And then...
And also...
Which was...
What was it?
Su-san?
Is that...
I don't know.
I just remember the melody.
And then...
What was it?
Su-wan.
Ton su-ka pum pum pum.
That's literally the only lyrics I remembered from that song.
From Dr. Shlump.
Like...
Literally...
The only car...
The only words I remember was like...
Su-wan Tonsuka pum pum pum.
And then...
So...
So they were like...
Oh, you can teach us these songs!
I was like...
No.
No, you don't understand.
I don't...
I can't...
Put the melodies...
So... I'm barely a student, let alone a teacher.
No, you should not put that responsibility on me.
So, that's why I was like...
Yeah, like... I don't feel...
I don't know.
I don't feel comfortable.
I was like, if we get somebody else to teach us, that would be...
That would be more ideal.
If we just get somebody else to teach us.
But yes.
Instead, we planned something else for the intermission part.
Because I was like...
It's not gonna go well.
If I was a teacher, it's not...
I'm so sorry.
Barely a student.
I'm barely...
I'm barely an English student.
Let alone...
Let alone a Cantonese student.
I'm barely...
And when I speak Cantonese, I put English words in things I don't know how to say.
That's...
So... So that happened.
I felt really bad.
Because like I was asking for like...
Last minute changes in the end.
Because I was like... I didn't feel comfortable with being a teacher.
But I still...
I hope people enjoy...
Yisun's concert.
Like... I...
I just...
Mr Game Boy thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They turn back to the original version.
So Cantonese version.
How nostalgic.
Which one?
There's so many.
Also, I'm gonna get a tissue box real quick.
I'll be right back guys.
I'll be right back.
I'm too lazy to get...
I'm too lazy.
Dad's at the groomers right now.
He's getting...
Oh my gosh, I shouldn't...
Sorry.
I stopped my son from making an edgy joke.
Give me a sec.
I'll be right back.
Sorry.
Sorry, I almost went Dr. Disrespect there, so...
Let me take a bite off of my sandwich real quick.
Alright.
As I was saying...
Bro, what the fuck does that tweeting make?
What the fuck?
Okay.
Alright.
Like, his new tweet, I'm just like, what the fuck, man?
Like...
I'm...
Jesus Christ.
Anyway.
Fucking internet is such a...
Twitter's...
Moments where people need to fucking...
get off the internet.
Honestly.
So yeah.
Dad's at the groomers right now.
He's trying to look pretty at the moment, so...
That's why he's not there.
Olympics!
Updates on the...
Updates on the Olympics.
Did you guys know they fucking swim in the...
The sand?
The river?
Like...
What's wrong with...
Like, what the fuck is wrong with them?
That river has not been cleaned in...
In like...
Hundreds of years.
Like...
For those who don't know...
I saw...
Okay.
There was like article of it.
I saw it.
I was reading an article because it showed up on Twitter.
Um...
Let's see.
Let me see if I can find it.
I like sent the article...
To my friend.
Because I was like...
Bro, that's fucking...
Disgusting.
I was like...
That's so...
Okay.
Alright.
I'll show you guys the picture.
I'm gonna save this real quick.
Um...
I looked at this.
I was like...
What the fuck is wrong with people?
Who agreed to this?
Alright.
Here's a picture.
Of people...
The water is brown.
For those who don't know...
What...
Um...
This river is...
It is a very old river.
That's been around for hundreds of years.
So, it's like Italy's...
Um...
What is it?
It's a moray.
What the fuck?
I'm trying to remember.
Like Venice.
Yes.
Sorry.
It's like Venice.
It's been a while since I've used my brain.
I've been not using my brain.
Like...
You know how like...
When I'm streaming, I don't use my brain?
Now, imagine that.
But like...
At an even lower percentage.
Like...
At 1% of that.
Just...
Just imagine 1% of...
That brain.
That's me right now.
So, I...
I literally...
I can't remember stuff.
So...
So, in Venice...
The...
The water in Venice...
Where they travel everywhere...
Um...
That's the sewage.
It's not clean either.
It's fucking...
Not clean there as well.
Don't touch the water there in Venice.
Um...
Now, imagine that.
But for Paris.
And people are gonna swim there.
For the Olympics.
That's...
I'm not saying Venice is the sea...
Is the river.
I'm just saying comparing the river...
The Seine river...
Um...
In Paris.
Comparing the...
The quality of that.
Who like...
The Venice water.
Cause that's literally where people dump stuff.
And like...
Dump trash.
And...
And the sewage water.
The Paris water has not been cleaned in hundreds of years.
Like...
Imagine back in the medieval days.
Where...
Fuck...
There's like...
Medieval poop in there.
That's how fucking dirty it is.
Like...
And then...
For the Paris Olympics...
I saw this picture.
I was like...
There's no way they're swimming.
It's...
The Seine is a beautiful song.
But everybody knows...
This is not water anymore.
Like...
Um...
And...
Apparently...
I was reading...
Cause I was reading the tweets.
And I was like...
Under the article?
Cause I get my news on Twitter nowadays.
Like...
Like everybody else in our generation these days.
And the cor...
Like...
We're a problem right now.
But I...
Like...
We get our news on social media.
On Twitter.
Um...
Like...
I'm not gonna pay fucking five dollars for Washington Post.
I'm sorry.
I'm not gonna pay five fucking dollars to read more on Washington Post when I can get it for free on Twitter.
Um...
Hahaha...
Anyway...
I was looking at it.
And apparently...
People were protesting the Olympics.
You know?
Cause they're like...
Oh...
Cause like...
A lot of places...
A lot of places where the Olympics is hosted.
They would spend millions of dollars for facilities and stuff.
And...
Like for facilities.
And like to build place things for the Olympics.
To build like...
Um...
Instead of like...
And people were like...
People got really mad about it.
Also it's France.
Also it's Paris.
And like...
It's apparently a thing where people like protest a lot in Paris.
So...
Hahaha...
This was...
Another thing to protest on.
So...
Um...
Obviously...
France invested millions of dollars to clean the river.
You know...
Clean like hundreds of years of fucking shit water in the Seine.
And...
Uh...
Hahaha...
And...
The protestors...
To...
To counteract...
They started pooping in the water everyday.
And I'm like...
Are you fucking kidding me?
People are actually currently...
Um...
Currently...
Shitting in the wa...
In the river.
To protest against the Olympics.
Um...
And...
It was...
It was so fucked up.
Because like...
I was watching the video.
And there was like this video of them like...
Checking the pH level of the river.
And...
By the way...
This photo is of Olympians...
Looking at...
Doing their fucking triathlon shit.
In here.
Haha...
Yeah...
Like...
Pun intended.
Um...
Hahaha...
And...
By the way...
The...
I don't know...
The ref or some shit.
They like...
Was like...
They checked the pH level.
And was like...
Yay!
It's an acceptable level!
And I was like...
I would not swim in an area...
Where the fucking Olympic referee...
Told everybody...
That the water is now acceptable to swim.
It's...
Acceptable should not be the term...
To describe like...
Hahaha...
That could not be the right word...
To describe the condition...
Of a swimmable water.
Like...
Hahaha...
What the fuck?
Why did they say...
Acceptable?
Haha...
Like...
It's like...
The water is good enough...
Like...
What the fuck?
Um...
Anyway...
So...
Other than...
I know like...
Everybody is like...
Oh...
I don't know...
Doki...
Have you seen like...
The...
The shooting...
Uh...
Competitions...
And all that stuff...
And like...
All the cool poses...
And everything...
But like...
Nobody is talking about the shit...
What...
Like...
Everybody knows about that stuff...
But like...
I'm here to talk about this...
Because this is a problem...
Hahaha...
This is...
Like...
Um...
This is a problem...
Hahaha...
This is...
Just...
I think...
This is not a good thing...
Something's not working...
Like oh...
Um...
That was the reason...
That he didn't feel...
It was just parents attends the Speca...
The mess...
What do you mean yes...?
Was laying in over...
That's...
I think...
I th...
That's why...
It's been like that because it was a pollute- it was been polluted it was It's been polluted for so long That's why I'm like we can't just fix it in a year
If a river has been polluted for hundreds of years I feel like it's not just gonna be fixed instead of a year
Oh my god!
This is medieval poop water!
Anyway...
I just don't think people should have swam in Lassen.
I just...
Dude...
We have other sources of water!
I just think we have other sources of water!
Oh...
But yeah, that was...
I don't know, I just...
I just thought that was the craziest shit I ever saw.
I thought...
I just thought that was like wild.
I don't know.
If it's been polluted for thousands...
For like, apparently 2000 years.
I don't know, it just feels...
I don't know.
Nobody wants to touch Venice's water?
Like...
That is crazy too!
It's like, this is why I don't swim in the ocean!
This is why I don't do beaches.
I don't touch ocean water.
Like, I know.
I know, like...
It could be different.
But like...
It's just...
Everybody poops in the ocean!
And then there's microplastics in the ocean!
There's literally a giant floating...
I know, I'm fucking paranoid as hell.
But like...
I don't know, like...
It's not like I'm a germaphobe.
Or anything.
It's literally nature's toilet.
And...
Um...
And like...
Like, there's...
There's trash island!
There's...
There's a fucking ocean!
And...
The ocean is the Earth's toilet!
And it's just...
I don't know.
And then fucking Steve Irwin died in the ocean!
Like, I don't want...
What if there's a stingray?
What?
But like...
You're like...
But Doki...
Doki...
That was like a one in a million chance!
Yes, but there is a one!
There is...
Somebody has to be that one!
But...
What if I...
I've been unlucky?
What if somehow I'm the one?
I'm the one!
It ain't zero!
Exactly!
Like...
Real...
And then there's like jellyfish too.
I don't want to know what it's like to be stung by a jellyfish.
Guys...
Like, I...
I really...
I don't want to be...
When...
I don't want to be the one!
To be stung by a jellyfish!
I don't want to hit the lottery!
There's like...
Somebody has to hit the lottery!
I don't want to be that somebody!
It sucks, but...
It sucks, yes, but I don't want to experience it!
I don't want to experience it!
Like...
I'm happy to die never experiencing a jellyfish stung seeing me.
Because apparently it's a high percent...
Like what's the odds of getting stung by a...
Odds...
Of getting stung by a...
Jellyfish...
Alright...
How common?
As many as a hundred and fifty million jellyfish stings occurs around the world each year?!
I could be in that one fifty million!
One fifty million is way too high!
Actually...
That is actually very high.
Like I...
One hundred and fifty million!
Like...
By the way peeing on a jellyfish sting is considered stinging and not stinging.
This is an urban myth that actually does... it's been... it was... it was spread by some sick fuck that wanted to get peed on.
Because it does not help, by the way.
Even I know that.
Peeing on the wound does not help.
Some fucking weird... weird guy was like...
Was like, oh guys, what if you pee on it?
Like, I heard it's helpful.
And then apparently it spread... it spread everywhere.
And now people think it's a real thing.
But it's a... that's a myth.
That's not real, by the way.
Yeah, that is... that is not real.
Don't ruin it for the weird...
So if your friend got stu... if your friend...
They might not even have been stung by a jellyfish.
If your friend...
Or your loved one...
Or your...
Or like, I don't know, co-worker or anything...
Goes up to you... you're at the beach...
And they go up to you...
And was like, I got stung by a jellyfish.
Please pee on it.
They're a weird fucking asshole.
They're a sick fuck.
And then you'll know...
And then you'll be like, thank you Doki for telling us this.
My weird friend... my friend actually just ran up to me and was like...
Asked me to pee on their jellyfish thing.
Now I know.
Now I'm gonna kink shame him.
Or her, I don't know.
Like... stings are not like exclusive to one gender.
Like...
It's not like they see... they see a man and it's like...
Oh my god, I'm gonna sting that guy.
So like, don't worry.
They're very inclusive to everybody.
Um, it doesn't matter to them if you get like stung.
Um...
Porziro, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You should rub it with sand.
I mean, sand is everywhere if you're at the beach.
So, it'll be fine.
Um...
Real homies pee on this thing no matter what.
Oh my god, what if the...
The odds of it helping.
Thank you for the super chat Deadpool.
Thank you.
Also, drinking pee does not help by the way.
It's actually very dangerous.
Do not drink pee if you're like...
stuck in a deserted island.
You're stuck in the desert.
And you can actually die.
From drinking piss.
That's a myth also.
Do not do it.
Like, I don't know.
If you're ever stuck in a desert...
And like...
I actually looked this up.
Cause I was like, is that real?
It was invented by like fucking Bear Gryllis.
Or whatever his name is.
Um, Bear Gryllis literally perpetuated this myth.
About drinking piss.
To survive.
In like, uh...
He literally...
He literally invented this fucking myth.
Like...
Just for TV.
It's not...
It's not real.
It's...
It's actually...
Bear Gryllis... Yes, he lied to you.
He went to a hotel.
In the middle of filming.
Like...
Like... This man...
If you researched Bear Gryllis...
During like the film...
Filming of his show.
He literally went to a hotel.
In the middle of it.
He wasn't even surviving.
He actually lived in a resort.
In the middle of filming the show.
Um...
Anyway...
Like he drank piss for no reason.
Just so you guys know.
There was no reason for him to do it.
Um...
Anyway...
You're telling me I've been living...
Yes!
Reality V...
Is not very real.
Just so you guys know.
It's not...
It's not how to survive.
Anyway... The reason why...
You should not drink piss...
Is that you can actually get dehydrated.
Because it's salty.
You will thank me later...
If you're stranded in a desert.
Okay guys... Instead...
I will drink some water.
So...
And it has a lot of bacteria.
So you would die faster.
Um...
Anyway...
Don't listen to Bear Gryllis for survival tactics.
Um...
Just so you guys know.
Do not listen to Bear Gryllis.
I know like...
Everyone are like...
Who the fuck is Bear Gryllis?
Oh thank god.
Yes.
And then the older generation would be like...
Oh my god I'm so old.
But...
Instead...
You listen to Ted Bear.
That's the only bear I'll trust.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Bear Gryllis.
Bro he hasn't been relevant for years.
Of course I'm gonna...
Forget his name.
He hasn't been relevant in so long.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Who is Ted Bear?
Okay.
You just made like...
Some dragoons feel very old.
Ha ha ha.
Jonathan Perry.
Thank you Super Chat.
Thank you.
So if I'm stranded in the desert, I'll survive better if I live in a hotel.
Got it.
Yes.
Maybe you have zero surviv...
Also why the fuck would you be alone in the desert?
Who the fuck goes to the desert alone?
That's like asking to like...
Die alone.
Like I don't know.
Why would you?
Why would you ever?
I don't know.
Go to the desert alone.
Why?
Speaking of like...
You could be like...
What's his name?
The guy that's like the best rock climber in the world.
I like looked at...
I was like...
Um...
Alex Honnold.
I think that's his name.
Yeah.
So there's this guy.
I was like reading about it today.
Um... I live in a desert country.
Yes but there's civil...
But I meant like you know...
Like the middle of the desert.
You know what I mean?
Not like where there's no civilization.
Like why would you go to the middle of the desert alone?
Or this guy.
Unless you're that guy.
Apparently that guy has no fear.
He has brain... There's something wrong with his brain.
Where he cannot feel fear.
Or like the less... less fear.
That's why he's like the best rock climber.
Like the best like...
Rock climber in the world.
Because he literally cannot fear anything.
And I was like reading like...
A thread about him.
Cause I was like who the fuck is that guy?
Because they were talking about like...
Um...
They were talking about...
Uh...
Like Olympians or whatever.
Cause like...
Cause Michael Phelps...
The reason why Michael Phelps was able to win...
A lot of...
I don't know if he's dead yet.
Literally his girlfriend begged him to stop doing rock climbing.
And then...
And then he straight up told her...
By the way they have a child together.
They straight up told her...
That like...
He was like I am under no obligation to spend my life span.
Like what the fuck?
Imagine telling your wife...
Like...
They have a child!
Oh my god!
Anyway...
Um...
Anyway as I was saying...
It came from like...
Cause I was like looking at...
I was reading up this thing about Michael Phelps.
By the way Michael Phelps...
Literally entire body is designed to swim.
Cause he's like a fucking...
I don't know like fucking genetics.
It's wild.
And the only reason he got into swimming is because he has like ADHD.
And like his mom...
Threw him in the pool.
To waste his energy.
Which I...
It's not like he wanted...
He grew up and was like I love swimming.
He was like...
Cause mom was like you have too much energy.
I'm gonna put you swimming classes to waste your energy.
Like...
Like what the fuck?
Um...
His body is literally built for swimming.
He's like double jointed or whatever.
Like he has like double jointed ankles.
So when he kicks...
When he kicks the water...
Um...
It basically...
When he kicks the water he like...
Goes further because he's double jointed.
And then...
And then apparently...
I mean look at this shape.
Look at the shape of his...
He has very long arms.
Like look at the shape of his body.
You can tell it.
That is not like anatomy wise.
That is not right anatomy.
And...
And the reason why he's like...
Known as the best swimmer in the world is because...
Not only does his like...
Fucking body build different.
His like...
The chemicals.
Like the chemicals in his body...
Like, whatever acid or whatever... there's like an acid that is produced that causes tiredness or whatever.
That makes you... you know, the more you work and the more of this... what was it?
Lactic acid that's produced.
And the more it produces, the more tired you get.
This man's fucking body produces half of a normal Olympian.
Like... what the fuck?
Like... it's just like a typical athlete.
You know that they have less lactic acid than like a normal person like us.
Like, I don't know.
I'm pretty sure there's no like Olympians here in my chat.
Because you're here watching the stream instead of training for the Olympics.
It's not over yet.
Or partying at the Olympic Village.
So like, he has half of a regular Olympic athlete.
So...
So like...
A regular Olympic athlete...
Already has less lactic acid than a normal person.
Now Michael Phelps has half of that.
That's so fucking crazy.
He's literally built to swim.
Like...
That's insane.
That's just... biologically he's just built different.
Nervous man.
Yeah.
Nothing but insurance.
Oh shit.
Braum Pro is here.
Hey Braum Pro!
Hey man.
Um...
But yeah, he's...
Yeah, it's actually...
It's actually crazy to think about.
So yeah, anyway.
The reason why I got to Michael Phelps is because I talked about this rock climbing dude.
But that's... like...
I love like...
I don't know if this is true.
But like this was in the article.
About that guy that has no fear processors.
And like...
I was like...
I love this quote.
It's such a good quote.
Like from a scientist.
Like...
That kid's amygdala is in fire.
It's like...
It's like a doctor's way of saying like...
That kid ain't right.
Like...
Yo, that kid ain't right man.
Because like...
Something ain't right about this child.
But yeah, that's why he's able to climb.
Like if you guys have ever looked at this...
What's his name?
Um...
I'm not talking about Michael Phelps.
I'm talking about the other guy.
The rock climbing guy.
I literally told his girlfriend like, why do I need to extend my lifespan for you?
Like, Jesus Christ.
His fucking girlfriend who has a kid with him.
Um, he was like, Alex Honnold.
Yeah, Alex Honnold or whatever.
Um, yeah.
Um, that's why he's able to...
Like, for those who don't know how crazy the stuff he does.
Let me pull up like some... because I looked him up.
I was like, who the fuck is that guy?
Like, he's apparently really famous.
I was like, who the fuck is he?
And then I looked up photos.
And I looked up the photos.
Yeah?
And then I see the climbs he does.
I was like, oh that scientist was definitely right.
Like... I was like, oh yeah, no.
He's... he does not fear anything.
And don't worry, I'll show you guys what I mean.
Yeah.
Um...
I saw this and I was like, holy fuck!
That... that kid ain't right.
That kid ain't right.
Like...
What's... amygdala?
That's where... that's the part of your brain that produces fear.
That's what it is.
This man doesn't produce fear.
Um...
This getting over... what if getting over it was real?
He's a difficult... he's a guy from the difficult game about climbing!
That's him!
He's the climber bro!
It's that game!
Something wrong with that... something wrong with that boy.
Um... but yeah.
And you're like, how old is this man?
That's a good question.
He's like 38?
He's 38 and holy fuck!
Like you took this from like... somebody younger!
You know!
This man's 38!
Oh my god.
Um...
But yeah.
That's him.
Not for long.
But anyway.
That's my... that's another life update here.
That's my...
that's another life update here.
Like shit I'm reading.
Stuff I... stuff that shows up on my...
Um...
On my Twitter feed.
But yeah.
It's been...
It's been like...
Um...
It's been a wild...
Oh speaking of wild week.
But speaking of Olympics.
I'm so sad.
They're not making...
Did you guys hear?
I don't know if this is true or not.
Um...
But like apparently...
The reason why...
We don't have...
Um...
We don't have another Sonic and Mario...
Olympics game.
Is because the Olympics decided to go for NFTs.
Like...
Four years too late.
Like what the f...
Like...
Bro...
They could have done that four years ago.
Like...
I don't understand.
Who's still investing in NFTs?
Who's still...
I can right click save...
A PNG.
Um...
But yeah.
They decided to be like...
We're gonna go for it with...
Having NFTs instead of Sonic and Mario Olympics.
Which...
I don't know.
Really weird.
They could have done that four years ago.
It would have been more relevant four years ago.
They would have actually made money four years ago.
Because back then, nobody knows jack shit about NFTs.
Like, nobody knew that NFTs are mostly pump and dump.
But like, I guess...
I guess the Olympic Committee didn't find out about that.
So that's why we're not...
That's why we're not getting another Sonic and...
Sonic and Mario Olympic Games.
No, not your regular people.
I don't know if you guys know this.
But NFTs got so popular that regular people were investing into it.
Because they didn't know it better.
That's how you got all those scams.
From like, you know...
Like Logan Paul.
No, Doki.
You're Logan Paul.
Logan Paul.
Who the fuck...
I don't want to fucking collab with Logan Paul.
No, your Prime...
Prime tastes like shit.
Because it's an energy drink.
Prime sponsors.
Crazy.
I don't know why they sued for having an opinion.
I live in NA.
But they're gonna fucking...
Everybody said it!
It's not just...
If they're gonna sue me because I said Prime is shit.
And that like...
And that Logan Paul still has that fucking NFT scam.
That he still hasn't...
You know what doesn't taste like shit?
Uh...
Gamer subs.
By the way, if you use my code Doki...
Freaking...
Doki, be careful.
You can't say Logan Paul is a scammer.
He's suing a YouTuber for doing just that.
Thank you for the super chat, Chie.
Thank you.
Bro, if he sues me...
The amount of publicity I will get from that...
Like...
Because I said in one fucking...
I didn't make it 20...
I didn't make a fucking one hour docu-series about it.
Like...
Like, he's suing the guy that made the one hour plus docu-series.
It's not even bad publicity for me.
It's bad publicity for him.
Because he's suing a fucking random VTuber.
Like, what the fuck is wrong?
He's fucking...
He has millions of dollars.
Like, I...
If I had that...
As much money as Logan Paul...
I would fucking...
Do better stuff with my time.
Like...
Did you guys see what's going on for MrBeast right now?
Bro, everybody's getting...
Everybody's getting cancelled.
Like, bro...
Every...
Everybody's getting cancelled.
Bro...
I'm getting cancelled right now.
It's actually insane.
Like...
Apparently...
For those who live under the rock...
Um...
There...
There was like a huge thing that got released or something.
Like, you tell all...
On MrBeast.
By the way, Feast...
Everybody knows Feastables taste like shit.
Like, I don't...
I...
I don't understand.
Like...
Every...
Everybody knows...
Feastables does not taste good.
Like, it's not a good chocolate brand.
Like...
I tried it once and it's fucking dog shit.
Um...
But...
Everybody's getting cancelled right now on the internet.
I...
To be fair, MrBeast has always had like a lot of people trying to cancel him.
But like...
Apparently...
The newest vid...
I watched like half of it.
Cause it's like...
The video's like almost an...
Wait, how long is the video?
I actually literally have it in my history.
I watched it last night.
Cause I was...
I thought it was a joke.
But then like...
Cause like...
The comic section was really funny.
Like...
That's why...
Cause you know, before you watch the video, you read the comments, right?
Like for the...
Like the...
I do that.
I read the comments just to...
Yeah, like...
See...
Get like an appetizer about what's going on.
You know?
Like...
I don't know.
But...
It's like an appy.
Like I'll be like...
Oh, okay.
Let's see like...
What's...
What could be going on.
And then...
The comic section for that video was so fucking wild that I thought it was a joke.
Cause I was like...
MrBeast is always trying to get cancelled.
So like...
What's the difference this time?
And then like...
I read the comments.
I was like...
Oh, this has to be a joke.
Right?
And I watched a video and I was like...
Oh, this is not...
This is real.
Yeah, this is an hour long...
I didn't watch an hour of it.
Because like...
Um...
He put a lot of memes into it.
So...
I was just like...
That's why I didn't take it seriously.
I...
I did take it seriously because there was like...
It was filled with like memes and stuff.
And...
The guy got sent a cease and desist letter.
And then he made a meme video too.
But then I like watched half of it.
Like...
I think like I watched the la...
Like I watched the beginning a little bit and then I skipped to the end.
Um...
And then...
So...
I was like...
Wait...
That shit's pretty bad.
Like...
Yeah, he got a cease and...
Like literally...
If you look at the comments...
I didn't...
I didn't think it was real.
I didn't think this video was real because I was looking at the comment section.
And...
And somebody was like...
You know what?
I'm sorry to think MrBeast might not even be his real name.
And I was like...
Of course if I see that...
I thought it was a joke.
Yeah...
I was like...
I...
I thought the video was a joke because I saw...
That's literally the top comment.
So like...
Of course I didn't take it seriously.
Like...
And then I watched the video and I was like...
Oh shit.
There's some serious allegations in there.
Um...
But this is what I mean.
This is literally like the top comment on that video.
Like...
So, yeah...
That's why...
That's why I didn't think it was like, oh, this has to be a joke vid.
It has...
By the way, this video has 9 million views.
So I was like, whoa, that's a lot for a one hour video.
But yeah, everybody's getting cancelled.
Yay.
I feel like that's...
That's basically a lifespan of a creator.
If you create long enough, you'll eventually get cancelled.
No, it absolutely is a sarcasm.
That's why I thought that was a joke video.
This year's been fucking wild.
It has been.
Oh my god, I had the scariest experience, by the way.
Here's another life update.
I had like one of the scariest experiences living like in my apartment alone.
And like, it was fucking crazy because...
Because like, I got woken...
My door was open.
My bedroom door was open.
And...
And usually I have it closed.
If I'm like...
I'm not alone.
But like...
But then I had it open because I was like, okay, I'm alone.
And...
No, this isn't my current...
Like, my current place.
Not my new place.
And then...
Dad...
Woke up...
And started barking...
At the door.
Like, outside...
Like, at the door.
Like, on my bed.
And I was freaking out.
Because I was like...
It was like...
Three in the morning?
It was three in the morning.
I don't even remember what day this was.
But it was three in the morning.
And then...
I was like...
What the fuck?
Like, I was...
Because like...
He's never done that before.
And so then...
I closed the door.
Because I was like...
Oh no.
Like...
I closed the door.
Because I was like...
What's going on?
And then...
So...
And then I just like...
Looked at the door.
And then I looked at dad.
And then dad...
Was like...
Like...
And then he was like...
Like, he kept growling.
He kept growling.
And I was like...
And I was like listening.
And I didn't hear anything.
And then...
So then I was like...
Then I...
Because I was really...
I was really freaked out.
You know?
I was like...
So fucking freaked out.
And then so like...
I opened the door dad.
And I pushed...
Why get a dog if he's not going to help protect you?
So like...
I opened the door.
And I...
I slapped his butt to push him out.
And then...
And then he like walked out.
And so I was like...
I don't know!
I was scared!
And...
And so...
So I...
I did like a playful slap.
Like...
You know?
Eee...
And then push...
And then push him out of the door.
He walked away!
He's locked out!
It's not like he restrained himself.
Look, somebody superchatted me too while I'm telling this story so I'm not a bad person.
And it was their first superchat.
Like, J.D.
Ward, thank you for your very first superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
So, it's not like he like...
It's not like he like, fought back.
He willingly left the door.
I just gave him a little motivated push.
So...
Um...
He walked out.
And then...
And then he like, barked a little bit.
And then he walked back inside.
Like, he came back.
And then looked at the door and started going...
So obviously...
That freaked me out.
Like...
He went outside.
Walked a little bit further.
But then he came back.
So...
Obviously...
I was freaking out.
And then...
Yeah...
Like, it's 3 in the morning!
Like, what the fuck?
I've never had this experience before.
I've never...
It's probably a cat.
I live in a very high...
I live in a very high floor.
I don't think a cat...
Is gonna be like...
And like...
There's like the entrance...
Like my entrance door...
Is like further away from the living room.
So like you have to like walk like a bit to get to the entrance way.
Cause it's like a hallway.
It's like a hallway from that to the living room.
And then...
And then like...
And so then I was freaking out.
So I looked outside.
I see nothing.
Obviously.
I don't know what the fuck I was thinking I was gonna see.
Like I don't know!
Cause like I've never had that happen before!
So I closed the door!
Cause I was like...
Okay but what if there was something and I didn't see it?
You know?
And then...
I was on my phone.
I wasn't playing any videos on my phone cause I was like I shouldn't make any noise.
I shouldn't make any sound or noise.
Because I was freaking out at 3 in the fucking morning.
I was like freaking out!
I was texting some friends about what's going on.
Cause what the fuck is happening?
Never before dad's done this before.
This has never happened before.
Um...
Ever since like...
Like ever.
Like in my life with dad.
This has never happened before.
Um...
So...
So I just sat there.
Like on my bed.
And then dad was looking at the door.
Occasionally growling at the door by the way.
And then...
And then like...
And then we both heard something outside the door.
Like I don't know how to explain it.
We both heard something.
I don't even know what it is.
I heard something.
It was like...
I think I just got my first paranormal experience.
It was fucking crazy.
Like...
Like that.
This is the sound I heard.
This is like my sandwich paper.
But it was like this.
Sort of.
But like...
Like that.
Outside my door.
But it's not like directly outside my door.
There's no way a raccoon would be like...
I live in an apartment.
There's no way a raccoon has climbed up to this floor.
And so it's high up enough that a raccoon will not be there.
Did you see it?
I don't fucking know.
And then obviously...
Dad freaked out and started barking.
Really aggressively.
He started barking aggressively again.
And I was just like...
I heard that.
And I opened the door.
I was like, I don't know.
I was like, if I'm gonna die up here...
I wanna see what it is.
I don't fucking know.
Like, there's only one door.
I can't... I'm not at ground level.
So I'm trapped, you know?
I was... I was trapped.
And...
The door is like...
There's only one entrance slash exit.
So...
I opened the door again after a while.
And then...
Because I have to pee too.
Okay, to be fair.
The reason why I suddenly got so brave was like...
I had to pee.
Like...
So I was like...
I am...
If I am going to get haunted...
At least let me pee.
Yeah, anyway...
Anyway...
Like, I had to use the bathroom.
So like...
So like, I opened the door.
Nobody.
And I just turned on...
I went to the living room.
Turned on the lights.
And then went to the bathroom.
And I was like...
Okay.
I don't know if...
And then dad got calmed down.
Dad wasn't barking or growling anymore.
Because like...
He also...
I also forced him to be outside too.
Because I was like...
If I'm going to be turning on the lights...
Like...
You're going to be there.
You know?
Like...
So he went...
You know, he went to the living room too.
And like he...
He fucking like sat on his like...
Dog bed.
And just looked at me.
And I was like...
Okay, everything's fine.
You're not freaking out anymore.
And then I went to the bathroom.
Went back to bed.
I was like...
And then I went to bed.
And I slept.
And then like...
And then I slept.
And then I remember like...
My friends are texting me.
Because like...
I didn't reply back.
After I was like...
I'm going to...
Because like...
I was messaging my friends.
And then I was like...
I'm going...
I need to pee.
I need to use the bathroom.
So I'm going to go out right now.
And then...
I didn't give them an update.
I can't...
And so...
I didn't give my friends an update.
I just went straight to bed.
And I woke up and I received like...
Panic messages and like...
Calls and they're like...
Because they're like...
We thought...
You didn't know what happened.
That was the last message you sent?
So I...
I was like, I'm so sorry!
I fell back asleep, I was so tired!
I was like, yeah, I fell, sorry, I fell back asleep!
Sorry!
I felt so bad!
No, my god!
Thank you, MagentaSoupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Um...
Yeah, yeah, so...
So, so that happened.
That's what I'm saying, I've been so fucking unlucky!
Like, apparently now I'm getting haunted?
Like, pick a struggle!
Like, I don't know, send, don't send all this fucking bad luck shit all at once!
Like, fucking wait a couple of months!
Now I'm fucking apparently haunted too!
Thank god I'm not living here anymore!
Um, I'm moving.
I'm literally moving, like, fully next week, so...
Um, good luck to me, I guess!
Um, but I really did miss streaming!
I really miss streaming for you guys!
And, um, just talking with you guys, hanging out...
Oh my god, it's already been two hours?!
It did not feel like two hours!
Um...
It definitely did not feel like two hours at all.
Um, but next week, there's so many exciting things next week!
Um, I'll be having my concert next week with Mint, um, at Anime Revolution, for those who don't know.
Um, it is, it comes, it's free entry, so as long as you have a pass there, it's on the 9th!
So, as long as you have a pass there, um, you basically get in, and like, there's a lot of, um...
There's basically, like, a lot of seats, so you don't have to worry about it.
I also have, like, a meet and greet and panel there as well, so...
Boop boop!
There it is!
We're gonna have a concert!
Let me see, where's the other picture of it?
Where's my pretty, like, straight up Anime Revolution picture?
Is it this one?
No, that's not it.
There's so...
I've been... There's so many conventions that I'm losing track of time.
Oh, and then there's Animathon too!
Right after, so...
There you go.
The tomatoes.
Oh, me too!
Anime Revolution, and then right after that, I have, um...
Animathon.
So that's right after.
That's right after that.
Um, and that is in Edmonton.
So there's one in Vancouver, and then the other one is Edmonton in Canada.
So, for you Canadian goons out there.
And then... Yeah!
And then next week, I'll be also doing a Twitch Rival.
I got invited to two different Twitch Rivals, um, next week, but then I rejected one.
And, um, I got invited to the Elden Ring one, but then I said no, because they wanted me to be level 150, um, for it.
I was like, I do not have time to...
My first Elden Ring stream is not for Twitch Rivals.
I literally was like, I cannot do Elden... Like, I'm not doing my first Elden Ring playthrough just for Twitch Rivals.
So...
Yeah, so I was like, yeah, I'm not... I said no, but then I said yes to the Apex one.
So I'll be doing the Apex Twitch Rivals next week.
Um...
So yeah, that's the only thing I have sort of planned.
I don't know what else I'm doing next week, so I'll figure that out.
But I'll figure that out soon.
I always figure stuff out last minute.
Um...
But yes!
That's my current plans, I think.
Um, but I'll be back to streaming more regularly.
So there... Look, I was so scared.
I'll be on break because like, um...
And he's on Fortnite?
Nothing.
I think... I don't know what happened.
It has... It's something related to the Fortnite Twitch Rivals event I did.
But like, Doru didn't get... didn't get... kicked out of the creator program.
So I don't know what happened.
Like, I... Like, Twitch has actually messaged Fortnite for me to ask what's going on.
So I'm just waiting on that.
Um, I messaged Fortnite myself, but like, no replies.
So like, it's so weird.
It's actually so weird.
And the thing is, it happened... Like, I did the Rivals event two weeks ago.
And then they... They like, kicked me out of the... They kicked me out of the program two days...
Like, I don't know what day.
Like, three days ago?
I got kicked out of the program three days ago.
So they waited two weeks to kick me out.
So I was so... Cause if it... If I said something weird...
Or like...
I didn't think I said anything weird.
I just did... I was my normal self.
I was my... I was my normal self in... In the event.
Like, how I usually stream.
And then like... So like, if I did say something weird, it would not take them two weeks.
Um...
Two weeks to like...
Uh... Kick me out of the program.
Like, I can still use the account.
I just don't have a creator code.
And I can't do... Um...
I can't do like...
Uh... Custom servers anymore.
Um... So like...
And then I messaged support.
I did a support ticket.
And I was like, what happened?
And they're like, we investing...
And then I got an...
Bot reply.
Because...
When I got my account back.
Like the Fortnite account back a couple months ago.
I got a real person that signed off their name.
You know?
So like, they would sign their name off.
Saying like a real person.
Like, replied back.
And I had... Like, I talked to like two real people for that.
And then...
Um...
But this one.
I got an automate...
Like, I felt like it was a bot reply.
Because...
Um...
Because like...
It didn't got signed off by a real person.
And then all they said was like, you broke the creator guidelines.
Like the creator TOS.
So I was like, what the fuck?
So I read it.
I was like, I don't know what happened.
I was just a...
I was doing a regular Fortnite stream.
Like how I've always done them.
And like...
I'm pretty sure I've said worse things than other Fortnite streams.
Like...
I'm pretty sure.
And it can't be because I said condom skins.
Because...
Because literally the reason why I was taught the terminology of it was because of my duo.
Who said that shit all the time.
Like...
They were literally saying it with me.
Um...
And then...
So...
So then I sent another ticket.
And be like, could you please elaborate what exactly I broke in the creator guidelines?
Because I'm so confused.
And I sent in a VOD.
And be like, my duo was okay.
Like...
I don't understand.
And then...
Um...
Uh...
And...
And because I sent a VOD.
Be like, this is my duo.
And everything is okay.
Like, I don't understand.
And then they were like...
Uh...
Oh, sorry.
If you don't understand.
Then like...
Please check...
Um...
Please check the...
Please check how the...
The guidelines.
Like, literally almost...
It wasn't the same reply.
But then it was like...
It was like...
Um...
They just linked...
They didn't link me the same article.
It was a different article.
Like the eligibility to be a creator in the creator program.
Um...
The thing is, nothing happened to him.
That's the thing.
Like, if it was something related to like what I did on that stream.
He would also get affected.
But nothing happened to him.
So I just wanted to see like...
Like, what the f*** was going on.
Um...
And then like...
Yeah.
And then...
So then...
And then they closed the ticket instantly.
So I couldn't like ask.
So I had to make a new ticket.
Uh...
I had to make a new ticket to ask about it.
Um...
So I was so confused.
Cause like...
I was like...
What?
What happened?
Like...
Anyway...
Twitch is trying to see what happened for me.
Cause they were like...
Cause you know...
It was from their event.
So they were like...
Okay, obviously.
You know...
They didn't want to have that affect me.
Because they were the ones that invited me to the event.
Like I...
The only reason why I joined was because...
Um...
They invited me.
So...
Twitch...
Twitch staff is gonna like...
It's like...
Already sent a message out to the Fortnite team.
To see like...
What the fuck happened.
Like...
I don't fucking know.
Cause I don't think we're getting our Fortnite skin, guys.
I don't...
Guys...
I'm in the...
For...
My...
Me getting kicked out of the creative program is gonna be on my permanent record.
No...
Guys...
It's gonna be on my permanent record.
I'm not gonna get sent to college now!!!
What will the university see?
Will they see my report card?
Um...
So...
I don't fucking know what happened.
Like...
They're lost on a podcast.
Potential Market.
But yeah, what was I talking about before the Fortnite shit?
I don't remember.
What was I...
Because I wanted to talk about something else and I went into the Fortnite tangent.
What was I talking about before the Fortnite stuff?
I forgot to.
I forgot.
No idea.
I remember.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
It was after the paranormal activity.
It was after the being haunted thing.
I mean, I'm moving out of here.
So like, good luck to the next tenant.
Unless it follows me home.
Then that's... that'll be an issue.
That'll definitely be an issue.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, I'll be in the...
Was I really talking about just Twitch Rivals before I got distracted?
Okay, anyway, I'll be at the Twitch Rivals.
The schedule.
Yeah, I haven't decided anything in my schedule other than the Twitch Rivals thing that I agreed to do.
Blow my nose real quick.
Give me a sec.
I'm extra stuffy right now.
But other than that...
Yeah, nothing else planned.
It's like... it's a draft system.
So like the usual Twitch Rivals for Apex.
They draft people for like...
Like a snake-wise way.
I don't know how to explain it.
I'm not a captain.
They were like, oh, what's your rank?
And I was like, plat.
I said don't play Apex often enough to justify my rank being high.
They're like, okay.
And I was like, yay.
Um...
Yeah.
Uh...
Yes, my PC is fixed.
It has an AMD card now.
Um...
Also another reason why I didn't stream for a bit was because...
You know, I was getting...
I can't believe...
I can't believe I lost to 50-50 twice.
Because apparently...
Because you know, my old PC is also Intel.
And see, Intel was a 13th gen that had issues.
And then...
So like, obviously, I lost to 50-50 for that too.
Because like, it's a 50% chance it's gonna...
Sorry, CPU.
I like to say card.
Because I like...
I don't know.
It's just...
It's just reflex.
Because I'm always...
Because usually in the past, it was my GPU that was the issue.
So I always like to say card.
But now it's my, like, CPU.
So, like, um...
My old PC, it wasn't...
It was Intel 13th gen.
This PC was 14th gen.
And it has a 50% chance of failing.
Guess who f...
Fucked up the gacha twice in a row.
Like...
So...
So I lost the coin flip in the 13th gen.
And the 14th gen.
That's why...
That's why I've been, like, blue-screening.
Because my...
My Intel card...
My Intel CPU kept playing...
Like, going crazy.
So, yeah.
I'm on AMD now.
And I changed my motherboard as well.
So...
So, yeah!
So, hopefully...
Hopefully, we won't...
We won't, like, go through another...
We won't go through some PC problems...
For now.
I don't know.
My luck has been really terrible lately.
Like I said, like...
My...
My luck has been incredibly bad.
So...
So, like...
Who knows?
I...
Okay.
I had another bad luck experience.
Um...
Uh...
I had another, like, bad luck experience.
For...
What was it?
Yesterday?
Because I was, like...
Um...
I was, like...
Trying to...
Trying to get, like...
Uh...
I was trying to get, like...
The elevator booked and stuff.
For, like...
Like, for moving stuff.
So, I was trying to get the elevator booked.
And then, they were, like...
Oh, sorry.
You have to...
Because, like...
At first...
But, like...
It worked out.
It worked out in the end.
Because I...
I, like...
I lied a little bit.
But, like...
It worked out.
It was a white lie.
And I was desperate.
So...
Because, like...
Okay.
So...
Basically...
Um...
I was, like...
I need a...
I need a move.
So, you're right.
So, you need to book the elevator for it.
Because I'm not fucking taking the stairs.
Because I live too high up.
And then...
So, like...
I went...
And was, like...
Hey, I need to book the elevator.
I talked to, like...
Um...
The person in charge for it.
And then, they were, like...
Yeah, that's no problem.
This date and this time.
I was, like...
Yeah, that's great.
And I went back up.
Went to take a nap.
Because I was fucking tired.
I'm always tired these days now.
Because everything is so boring.
Things a lot.
And then...
They were, like...
Oh!
They tried to call.
And then, like...
A couple of...
A couple of, like...
Uh...
Hours passed.
And then, they called me.
But I don't take calls.
Because, like...
I don't fucking know who the fuck calls these days.
So, like...
If they really want me to answer, they would text me or...
Or leave a voicemail.
Because if they're that desperate to reach me, they would leave a voicemail.
So, like...
They call...
Like, three...
Four...
Three...
Because, like...
Usually, it's spam.
Usually, it's fucking spam.
Like, telemarketers or robocallers.
So...
Um...
You know, they...
I was sleeping and I woke up because I got called, like, three times.
And then...
And then, like...
And then, the fourth time, they left a voicemail.
And they're, like...
We're so sorry.
We...
Please call us back because we can't do your appointment because you have to do it online!
And, like...
They're, like...
You have to give, like, X amount of times notice for it.
So, I was, like...
Because, like, the day I requested it, it was already past the deadline.
Um...
And then, I was, like, are you fucking kidding me?
So, I told a white lie.
I called them back.
I was, like, I'm so sorry.
I already paid the movie.
So, I can't change the date.
They're coming here regardless!
I ended up paying the movers the day after I got the call.
So I was like, dude, I already paid it.
So like, unless you're giving me the refund, like I can't change it.
They're gonna be here regardless.
So, thing is, I haven't paid them yet.
They were closed.
I was paying... I was gonna pay them the day after because they were closed.
So I had... like I held the appointment, but...
I held the appointment, but it wasn't fully confirmed.
And... so...
So obviously, the person... they were like, oh shit.
And they're gonna... well...
They're like, oh, okay, we don't really have anybody moving out on that date.
So like, you should be fine.
Like, that's fine.
Just... that's fine.
I mean, nobody was moving out on that date!
I don't... like... who... I'm sorry that you... the paper... like the fucking... like the bureaucracy about it.
Like, nobody was moving out.
Out on that date anyway.
It shouldn't matter.
It's just they need the fucking paperwork processed.
So it's like... it doesn't hurt anybody.
But yeah, I was able to book the elevator.
Yay!
Yeah, like it worked out in the end.
It worked out.
Like, everything was okay.
So... yippee!
It worked.
It didn't hurt anybody.
The lie didn't hurt anybody.
I just...
I beat the system!
And that's all that matters.
I beat the system.
Yeah, no fucking online shit is gonna... gonna ruin my fucking move.
Like...
Alright, guys.
Alright, I've been talking for two hours.
So I'm gonna call it here.
I'm gonna post my schedule either later today or tomorrow.
So we'll see.
Um...
Um, so... but...
It was great being back again.
I was so worried!
Because, you know...
I basically took like two... like one... a week break the week before.
So like... and then I took another week break this week.
So I was super fucking worried.
Because I was like...
Oh no!
What if dragoons forgot about...
Taking a break as a content creator is always so scary.
Like... and everybody knows I'm not one to take breaks.
Um...
So like...
I was obviously very scared.
Because I was like...
What if the dragoons forgot about me?
Ahhhh!
What if they've already moved on?
So I'm really happy to be back!
And I miss you guys a lot.
I really... I really did miss you guys.
I love streaming.
Um...
And...
I'm just glad to stream for you guys again.
And just talk to you guys.
It really means a lot.
For so many people to be here.
So many people to be here.
Um...
For my back stream.
It really means a lot.
Um...
And thank you everybody for the super chats.
And...
And the...
Gifted ships.
And joining the membership.
And subscribing.
Oh my god!
By the way...
I'm out of the shorts algorithm.
Like...
Who is this strange...
Who is this strange yellow creature?
Thank you for the super chat, Rice.
Thank you.
I'm unfortunate.
I need to get back onto the shorts algorithm.
Because I haven't uploaded...
I didn't upload...
It fucking sucks if I don't upload shorts consistently.
I'm out of the algorithm just like that.
I need them to know I'm alive.
I need...
I need the shorts algorithm to know I'm alive.
I'm sorry, YouTube.
I'm sorry I have a life.
Like...
So, I need to get back into the algorithm for shorts.
Anyway, I'm gonna call it here.
I still have lots of packing to do.
So, thank you everybody for welcoming back.
And for the red carpet for the super chats.
I'll try to have a super chat reading in the future.
Because there's so much super chats today.
Guys, it was moving so expensive.
There's so many expenses.
Like boxes.
And...
Um...
Boxes.
And moving companies.
And cleaning.
And the internet.
And then like f***ing electricity?
Oh my god.
I...
The expenses.
Internet.
I'm so...
Okay.
This is how little knowledge I knew about like being like a tenant.
You have to pay a deposit?
And rent?
Because like...
Okay.
Because I paid...
I didn't realize the deposit was different from rent.
Just like I paid the deposit.
And then I was like...
Yippee!
And...
Because it was a lot.
The deposit was a lot.
And then...
And then like...
The real agent was like...
Hey, Doki.
We still need the rent.
You haven't paid the rent.
And I was like...
But I did.
Like...
I...
I paid so much.
And then like...
No.
You have...
That's the deposit.
You got to pay that same amount.
But for like this month's rent.
I was like...
Oh...
The thing is...
Like...
I reached the limit of my e-transfer.
For those who don't know what e-transfer is...
I'm not going to tell you what it is.
Because I think it was like...
It's a...
It's a Canadian thing.
So, like, it's basically...
It's like...
You know, it's like a wire transfer.
But electronically.
So...
So, I was like...
I reached the limit of my e-transfer.
And...
I'm sorry, I need to wait 24 hours.
I was like...
I need a week!
I need to wait 24 hours.
Please.
Is it okay if we wait 24 hours?
Another request?
There it is!
And they're like, oh yeah, yeah, just like, um, just like, tell them.
You know?
Just...
Just like, tell them, you know, in the... in the...
In the... like, in the text.
I was like, okay!
So, that's basically...
That's basically what happened.
But it's a lot.
It's...
It's a lot.
I know we can't, like...
I'm glad I told that story because I'm supposed to e-transfer the rent now.
Like, cause the 24 hours is up.
But yeah!
Anyway guys!
Thank you everybody!
I really appreciate the support because...
Knowing... Now that, like, I know exactly how much...
Guys, this is...
This is why I'm saying...
If you had a choice between moving or not moving...
Don't move.
Just...
Just... I guess just stay there forever.
You live there now.
Cause like...
Oh my god.
This is...
That's a struggle.
Really, I'm just like...
Oh my god.
I should...
I'm just like...
No wonder people buy homes.
This is fucking torture.
Like...
Like, I was just...
This is... This is fucking terrible.
No wonder people have homes where they live there.
Forever.
And they die there.
Cause it...
It's just more convenient.
It's so much more convenient.
Why the fuck am I living in an apartment?
Also, like, imagine buying a house in my area.
Bro, fucking every...
All the houses are owned by Airbnb people.
Fuck Airbnb.
Anyway...
I need to go now.
As always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me...
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.